this video is brought to you by
surfsharkvpn
[Music]
hey wisecrack greg here today we're
going to be talking not about the most
famous animated sitcom of all time
but it's hipster brother that's right
futurama
matt granny's beloved series took us 1
000 years into the future
showing us the world of tomorrow and all
its slurm chugging
tube traveling glory now you might think
of futurama as a show full of math gags
sweet glide use variation of parameters
and expand neuron skin
heads and jars i recognize you didn't
you used to have a body of some sort
yeah but it was holding me back and the
single saddest thing ever put on
television
[Music]
and you wouldn't be wrong but the show's
futuristic setting also offers a pointed
takedown
of a defining belief in modern american
culture that technology
will save us all your mistletoe is no
match for my tow
missile we'll explain how in this
wisecrack edition
of futurama and before we continue i
want to give a shout out to this week's
sponsor
surfsharkvpn a vpn is a virtual private
network
which provides privacy anonymity and
security to its users
surfsharkvpn secures your data with
industry-leading measures by using
uncrackable encryption and the most
secure bpm protocols
it's fast easy to install and jam packed
with extra features
so you're really getting the bang for
your buck most vpns charge
extra to connect to multiple devices but
with surfsharkvpn
you can connect to an unlimited amount
with one subscription
that means that your phone laptop smart
tv
and even your console will be protected
by the industry leading encryption
check out surfsharkvpn today by going to
surfshark.dills
wisecrack and use the promo code
wisecrack
for 83 off an extra three months for
free
now back to the show futurama launched
in 1999 with granny using
all his simpsons clout to convince the
network to let him make a show that was
similar
but much weirder oh how convenient a
theory about god that doesn't require
looking through a telescope
get back to work it follows philip j fry
a regular 90s schmuck who gets
cryogenically frozen
and wakes up a thousand years into the
future the earth he encounters
is filled with bad mannered robots and
incompetent crustacean doctors
now open your mouth and let's have a
look at that brain
no no no no not that mouth i only have
one really it's also inexplicably
infested with owls
the show's sense of humor was way more
uh out there than the simpsons
each episode filled with esoteric
physics jokes
no fair you change the outcome by
measuring it
dark moral quandaries is it wrong to eat
intelligent animals
absolutely not linda and high concept
sci-fi bits
long before rick sanchez ever pulled on
a lab coat where does the other end come
out
you know i'm not quite sure dear me
futurama created its own unique universe
complete with an alien alphabet
and all kinds of odd touches and yet
earth circa 3000 is immediately familiar
to us
because it's based on a blueprint of the
future that's dominated our collective
imagination
for decades with its dome top buildings
smooth curves and sleek surfaces this
earth is largely modeled
after an architectural style called
populux or
googie if you're nasty a mold that
became popular in the mid 20th century
for its bold vision of the future it
captured the imagination of a post-war
america
that seemed to be rocketing towards a
brighter tomorrow the economy was
booming
creating a large middle class with money
to blow on all the latest household
gadgets
meanwhile the space race and the
emergence of atomic power
suggested boundless possibilities for
where humanity might go next
all this led to the rise of something
called techno optimism
that is the belief that advances in
technology
will generally make the world better
rather than worse
this pleasant vision of the future was
embodied by disney's tomorrowland
attraction in 1967
its house of the future was packed with
time saving devices
highlighting the revolutionary effect
technology would have on our lives
it was also constructed out of such
heavy duty plastic
that a demolition crew welding chainsaws
wrecking balls
and jackhammers struggled to tear it
down but where this vision of the world
of tomorrow was really cemented
was on 1960s television by the likes of
star trek
and even more relevantly the jetsons
this cartoon tale of a regular american
family
living up in 2062 has become such a pop
cultural touchstone
that even if you've never seen it you
still get the reference
and its futuristic elements remain some
of our go-to examples today
flying cars hoverboards and robot
helpers
and the show's influence on futurama is
immediately clear
the jetson's vision of the future is
also like futuramas
rooted in 1950s americana prominently
featuring populux architecture
clunky machinery and even a radio
antenna
but there's a critical difference while
the jetsons world is an easygoing utopia
where technology has ironed out many of
life's daily annoyances
futuramas is one in which technology has
mostly
just made those annoyances even more
obvious i had nothing to live for in my
old life
i was broke i had a humiliating job
and i was beginning to suspect my
girlfriend might be cheating on me
well at least here you'll be treated
with dignity now strip naked and get on
the probulator
according to the jetsons technological
advancements means
less work for regular people leaving
them free to enjoy their lives
mr jetson only works for a couple of
hours every week to support his cozy
white collar lifestyle
while his stay-at-home wife automates
almost all of the housework
and back then this probably seemed like
a reasonable projection
when time-saving gadgets like the
dishwasher were appearing all the time
look at all it holds in just one loading
the jetsons kind of just seemed like a
rocket power extension
of what was already going on even if
their fold-up flying cars are still not
available
at your local carmax futurama's world
similarly ramps up the speed at which
people live
flying cars are now the norm spaceships
are commonplace
and pneumatic tunes have been built for
even faster urban transit
but rather than saving time these
advances mostly serve
to move people more quickly to the jobs
they hate whereas the jetsons imagine
the future of work via
easy jobs like professional button
pusher
futurama imagines working people stuck
in
boring and dangerous jobs to make ends
meet
you gotta do what you gotta do because
while the technology needed to automate
work
does exist humans are as disposable and
cheap as ever this isn't a business
i've always thought of it more as a
source of cheap labor
like a family and man are their lives
undervalued
after all fry only gets his job aboard
the planet express ship
because the original crew was killed by
giant space washed
as luck would have it i saved the chips
from my previous crew
what's more the technology in futurama
hasn't expanded the choices available to
working-class people
it's constricted them by consolidating
the entire planet under one
all-encompassing bureaucracy from the
flashbacks of fry's life in the 20th
century
we can see how blue-collar people like
him easily found themselves stuck
working thankless dead in jobs
like delivering pizzas he was born
working class
and borrowing some minor miracle that's
where he's likely to stay
his life sucks so much that he's
actually happy to learn
that he's been randomly tossed into the
future my parents
my co-workers my girlfriend
i'll never see any of them again
but when he gets to the year 3000 pretty
much the first thing he learns
is that social stratification has been
neatly streamlined
everybody is outfitted with a career
chip that assigns them their place in
society which is how fry is able to wake
up a thousand years later
and still find himself in basically the
same place
the very real lack of upward mobility he
faced in the present day
is made literal in the future no not
again
of course it's not all science fiction
our real life dreams of the future have
morphed over time from everything will
be so easy
to everything will be so easy if someone
is pissing in bottles
to make it easy for you and the
gigification of the economy has
with revolutionary tech changes made
economic mobility
almost impossible as anthropologist
david graber wrote
nearly a decade ago about the so-called
magical potential of the computer they
have provided the means by which
employers
have created flexible work regimes that
have both destroyed
traditional job security and increased
working hours for almost everyone
which is to say we're all delivery guys
now
what's my job gonna be you'll be
responsible for
ensuring that the cargo reaches its
destination
so i'm gonna be a delivery boy and it's
not just delivery apps cheerfully
promising your food in under an hour
while also underpaying their workers any
utopian idea for optimizing your economy
may actually be a corporate scam in
disguise in futurama
the planet uniting under a single flag
doesn't make things better
it just clears the way for corporations
to more firmly establish themselves
as the real center of power the best
example of this is the mega corporation
minecorp led by a sweet old lady who is
secretly a vicious tyrant
like many of today's plutocrats mom
projects a public image of herself as
one of society's wealthy benefactors
providing vital public services from
which she just so happens to make
an immense profit get his pin number you
idiots
now i'm off to some charity bs for
knocked up teenage [ __ ]
mom has become one of the planet's most
powerful figures
by marketing her products as
technological advances
which will make life better but the
closer we look
the more sinister this promise seems mom
corp is actually directly responsible
for creating the robots that could have
ushered in a jetsons like future
but instead allowed her to become one of
the planet's de facto rulers
by making a product which the entire
planet uses
she can cut through the red tape that
applies to everyone else
engaging in business practices that are
both unethical
and destructive specifically it allows
her to pursue profitable technological
advancements
no matter the cost this robot will never
meet emission standards
crap spackle we'll just call it a sport
utility robot and classify it as a light
truck
futurama is totally up front about the
fact that humanity
has destroyed the planet by the year
3000 atlanta has sunk beneath the sea
new york as we know it is in ruins
beneath new new york
mla is well la but everyone is driving
around in cars shooting at each other
that's la for you
but the air is green and there's no sign
of civilization whatsoever
he just won't stop with the social
commentary the show also makes it clear
that greedy tech companies like mom corp
are responsible for the climate crisis
after all robots are the leading cause
of greenhouse gas emissions
if only i had made the effort to develop
a cleaner burning robot
but i was tired and in love take me now
you stud
and even when this is discovered these
massive corporations are too
powerful to face any real consequences
mom will never agree to reduce the
damage caused by her products
and that means reducing her profits so
instead
the leaders of earth find themselves
concocting other elaborate solutions
fortunately our handsomest politicians
came up with a cheap
last-minute way to combat global warming
emphasis
on cheap and last minute ever since 2063
we simply drop a giant ice cube into the
ocean
every now and then of course
since the greenhouse gases are still
building up it takes more
and more ice each time
thus solving the problem once and for
all note that these absurd solutions
which simply kick the can down the road
are seemingly the only realistic things
to do
because fixing the system is just so
hard the same sort of corporate friendly
ultimately apocalyptic banking
is also applied when they defend the
planet against a huge ball of garbage
by deflecting it with an even bigger
ball of garbage
what if the second garbage ball returns
to earth like the first one did
who cares that won't be for hundreds of
years
exactly it's none of our concern
that's the 20th century spirit this sort
of problem solving offers
a perfect caricature of the kind of
silicon valley tech
optimism we see today even when these
companies offer solutions
they have to stick within the very same
status quo
that created the problems they're trying
to fix short-term measures like
making apps to find clean drinking water
instead of you know not dumping toxic
sludge
into water supplies such solutions
intentionally fail to address
the root of any given problem because
doing so would upset the highly
profitable
status quo futurama's world is basically
a capitalist free-for-all where ads are
stretched across
every imaginable surface even inside the
customer's
own minds didn't you have ads in the
20th century
well sure but not in our dreams only on
tv and radio
and in magazines and movies and at ball
games and on buses and
milk cartons and t-shirts and bananas
and written on the sky
but not in dreams no siree earth is no
longer divided into nations
but carved up amongst whoever can afford
to pay for it and that goes beyond the
planet itself
the moon has also been colonized and
converted into a crass amusement park
complete with a botched version of
humanity's space traveling past
that's not an astronaut it's a tv
comedian and he was just using space
travel as a metaphor for beating his
wife
that's especially significant because
the quest to make it to the moon
was central america's techno optimist
narrative
if we could neil armstrong that there
was no telling what the future might
hold
luna park is a depressing testament to
where those bright-eyed predictions
might take us
each new frontier just becomes another
piece of real estate
for the highest bidder but it's just so
artificial
the gravity the air the gophers you
might as well stay on earth
watch today's billionaires bidding on
asteroids
and talking about mars colonies full of
indentured servants
and you have to say to yourself futurama
kind of got a point
this much money could feed a small
starving planet
but it doesn't in futurama earth bros
can travel to distant planets
have their injuries instantaneously
repaired and watch robots beat the hell
out of each other for fun
but they still live in a society that
regards them primarily as a highly
expendable resource
funneling the value they create up
towards their corporate overlords
with ever greater efficiency we see this
firsthand when master bureaucrat hermes
decides to revolutionize the structure
at a forced labor spa
cutting costs and maximizing efficiency
by pushing his laborers to work harder
than humanly possible is basically the
exact opposite of the future
we once dreamed of my hermes got that
hellhole running
so efficiently that all the physical
labor is now done by a single
australian man in the decades since
tomorrowland of the jetsons we've seen
technology progress
faster than ever today we have tons of
new gadgets
many of which they actually predicted
everything from video calls
to smart watches to automatic
dishwashers but what futurama emphasizes
by drawing a direct line between
its millennium and our own is that most
people don't get to enjoy
how dope progress really is a small
fraction of the population get
incredibly rich
while the rest arguably work harder than
ever before
just like mr jetson getting yelled at by
his boss via video phones
all working days can now be endlessly
extended
by emails that follow us wherever we go
that's unless your job has already been
replaced by an app
in which case sorry man but hey we're
probably next you know
futurama mimics techno optimus fantasies
of the past
precisely so they can undermine their
delusions uh
could one of you coffin stuffers please
carry me it shows a world where the more
things
change the more they stay the same so
what do you think wisecrack
is technology to be our salvation would
you rather watch videos hosted by deep
fakes
or is futurama cynicism a smarter way to
think about the future
let us know in the comments thanks to
all our patrons for your support
decimate that subscribe button like
you're a corporate overlord
with no regard for the future of
humanity and don't forget to ring that
bell
and as always thanks for watching man
[Music]
peace
[Music]